AROUND.
MY FRIEND BILL WEAR HAS THE
STORY.
>> Reporter: THIS IS PATRICK,
THE KIND OF DRIVEN COMPUTER WHIZ
WHO STARTS COMPANIES IN COLLEGE.
HE CAME TO NEW YORK HOPING TO
MEET SOMEONE IN TECH THAT WOULD
BUY IDEAS AND CHANGE HIS LIFE,
HE JUST DIDN'T KNOW IT WOULD BE
THE HOMELESS GUY ON THE WALK TO
WORK.
>> HE HAS SOMETHING ABOUT HIM.
I REMEMBER THINKING HUH, WHAT
WHO IS THIS GUY?
>> Reporter: WHAT DO YAW MEAN HE
HAD SOMETHING ABOUT HIM?
>> HE HAD FOUND BOAT CHAINS,
THESE OLD, LIKE, BOAT CHAIN
PIECES AND HE WAS BENCHING THOSE
AS I WAS WALKING, AND IT WAS
HALF VERY AND HALF.
>> Reporter: HE CALL FINDING THE
UNJUST LOW HOMELESS AND OFFER A
CODE.
HE WOULD APPROACH THE MAN THE
NEXT DAY AND OFFER EITHER $100
NO STRANGES ATTACHED OR A CHEAP
LAPTOP, THREE TEXTBOOKS ON JAVA
SCRIPT AND AN HOUR ADAY TEACHING
HIM HOW TO WRITE COMPUTER
PROGRAM S.
WHEN THAT BLOG HIT, IT WAS
CLUELESS, DEGRADING AND
HORRIBLE.
PEOPLE COMPARED YOU TO THE
VILLAINS IN TRADING PLACES.
>> DON'T I KNOW YOU TWO GUYS?
>> STEP INSIDE.
>> Reporter: WELL, PATRICK'S
SO-CALLED JOURNEY MAN HACKER GET
A JOB?
NO.
WILL THERE WILL BE A LAPTOP ON
SALE ON 58th TOMORROW?
PROBABLY.
YOU HAD TO MAKE A PROPOSITION.
>> YEAH.
>> Reporter: WHAT WAS THAT LIKE?
>> HE WAS VERY CHARMING THE
MINUTE I WALKED UP LIKE HEY.
I WAS LIKE, HI.
I'M PATRICK.
HE'S LIKE I'M LEO.
>> Reporter: THIS IS LEO.
AS A KID, HE WAS OBSESSED WITH
SCIENCE, ASTRONG ME, PHYSICS, HE
FELL IN WITH THE WRONG CROWD,
BECAME A FATHER TOO SOON AND
LOST HIS JOB AND HOME.
>> THIS GUY PATRICK WALKS UP.
>> Reporter: YEAH.
>> AND SAYS CAN I TALK TO YOU?
>> YEAH.
>> Reporter: WHAT GOES THROUGH
YOUR HEAD?
>> WOW.
>> Reporter: WHAT DID YOU THINK
HE WANTED?
>> I DIDN'T BELIEVE ANYTHING.
YOU GOT THE WRONG GUY.
NO, HE JUST SAID HEY, I HAVE
SOMETHING STRANGE BUT I'M
PUSHING AN OFFER AND INSTANTLY I
JUST SAID, IN MY MIND, DOOR
NUMBER TWO.
>> Reporter: AND THEN, THE
STRANGER ACTUALLY SHOWED UP WITH
AN ACTUAL LAPTOP, AND THOSE
LESSONS TURNED INTO AN
OBSESSION.
HE WOULD WRITE CODE FOR HOURS,
FOR DAYS ON THE BANKS OF THE
HUDSON OR IN A NOOK IN PRATT
TRICK'S OFFICE.
AT NIGHT, PATRICK WOULD GO HOME
AND LEO WOULD GO OUTSIDE.
SHELTERS AREN'T HIS THING, WHICH
SEEM FINE UNTIL WINTER BLEW IN.
HOW DO YOU STAY WARM ON THE
REALLY BITTER NIGHTS?
>> YOU GO TO THE TRAIN STATION.
>> Reporter: YEAH.
LIKE TONS OF BLANKETS.
>> IT'S GETTING REALLY COLD AND
I KEEP TELLING HIM THIS.
HE'S LIKE I'M GOOD, MAN, LET'S
KEEP GOING.
>> Reporter: PATRICK WANTED TO
GET HIM EMPLOYED AND HOUSED ASAP
BUT LEO HAD OTHER PRIORITIES.
WHAT DID YOU WANT TO DO WITH
THIS INFORMATION HE WAS TEACHING
YOU?
>> MAKE THE WORLD A BETTER
PLACE.
>> Reporter: HE'S A PASSIONATE
ENVIRONMENTALIST.
HIS HEROES ARE SCIENTISTS THAT
BRAVE THE RUGGED OUT DOORS.
>> THIS IS WHAT LIFE IS SUPPOSED
TO BE.
>> Reporter: COMING OUTSIDE?
>> YEAH, I WANT TO BE AROUND
PLANTS AND TREES.
I WANT TO BREATHE AS MUCH OXYGEN
AS POSSIBLE.
>> Reporter: SINCE HE'S REALLY
WORRIED ABOUT A CHANGING
CLIMATE, HE DECIDED TO USE HIS
SKILLS TO CREATE A CARBON
CUTTING APP CALLED TREES FOR
CARS.
>> AND IT SHOWS YOU EXACTLY
WHERE YOU ARE AT AND WHERE YOU
WANT TO GO.
THESE WOULD BE RIDERS IN THE
SAME AREA WHO WANT TO RIDE WITH
YOU.
>> Reporter: OKAY.
ALL TECH STARTUPS HAVE SNAGS BUT
IT WAS STALLED WHEN HE WAS
ARRESTED FOR SLEEPING ON A BENCH
AND POLICE TOOK THE COMPUTER AS
EVIDENCE.
NO HARD FEELINGS?
>> NO HARD FEELINGS.
I KNOW IT SOUNDS STRANGE.
I HAVE A LOT OF RESPECT FOR
AUTHORITY.
>> Reporter: THAT'S WHEN ANOTHER
GUARDIAN ANGEL ENTERED HIS LIFE.
HER NAME IS LOGAN AND SHE'S BEEN
FOLLOWING THE SAGA.
WHEN SHE HEARD ABOUT THE ARREST,
SHE TOOK TIME OFF, FLEW CROSS
COUNTRY AND GAVE HIM A COMPUTER
OF HER OWN.
SHE THINKS THIS FRIENDSHIP COULD
INSPIRE A NEW KIND OF MENTORSHIP
FOR COUNTLESS OTHER LEOS.
IF PATRICK WAS TEACHING LEO
ENGLISH, FEW WOULD CARE BUT
CODING IS A NEW AMERICAN DREAM.
>> AT THE END OF THE DAY YOU
DIDN'T GO TO COLLEGE BUT WRITE
EFFICIENT CODE, THAT'S AN
ENGINEER.
ON THE INTERNET, NO ONE KNOWS
YOU'RE A DOG.
>> Reporter: IF YOU MAKE MONEY
OFF THIS APP, ARE YOU GOING TO
GO GET AN APARTMENT?
ARE YOU GOING TO DO?
>> OF COURSE, CHUMP PLAZA HOTEL.
>> Reporter: IF HE DOESN'T MAKE
IT TO THE PLAZA, HE HAS FRIENDS
LIKE CITY WORKERS LOOKING OUT
FOR HIM.
>> I TELL GUYS DON'T JUDGE NO
ONE.
YOU NEVER KNOW WHAT A PERSON CAN
DO.
HE'S A GUN USE.
>> Reporter: AND THERE IS INNER
PEACE, ALL THE MONEY IN SILICON
VALLEY CAN'T BUY.
HOW DO YOU MANAGE TO KEEP SUCH A
POSITIVE